people have been getting tattoos since
day one for a reason some do it for
expression in identity some do it just
because it's cool which in my mind is
just as valid some people use them as
mementos and others get tattoos to heal
painful memories gummy come on my name
is Brian Finn I've been tattooing for 20
years here in Toledo Ohio Alexa asked
Delta to fill dog bowl I think what I
like most about tattooing and what drew
me to it was the freedom in 2015 I
decided that I was going to come in on
one of my days off and tattoo over scars
that were caused by human trafficking
self-harm and domestic violence I
wouldn't be Who I am today without my
past I started cutting when I was 17 I
felt like it was the only way to feel
things sometimes when I had dumbed
myself to the point where I wasn't
feeling anything it got really bad in my
early 20s and that's when most of these
scars are from that will be tattooed
over today
I think that I'm helping people by
finishing that chapter in their lives
they can go on to the next we don't have
a daily reminder Alexa asked the Delta
to fill one cup
[Music]
I think I'm really getting to a place in
my life where I'm moving past those
things and really comfortable with who I
am and I'm comfortable in my own skin
[Music]
I think that having the dragonfly on my
forearm will help remind me that I have
built this future for myself and I have
transformed and I am realizing who I'm
meant to be and I think that it will
help by covering the scars to avoid that
trigger a little bit that feeling of
wanting the pain again it's about
building more positive memories and
building a life worth living dragonflies
symbolize transformation and self
realization I'm building on the past and
building a new life for myself and
transforming and something beautiful can
grow from the pain
I think I choose to take the time to
help people out because a lot of people
don't take the time to help people out
so anyone that is looking for a tattoo
for whatever reason I will be here
you
you